Christina starts off this hour in
Chicago hi Christina welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi Dave thanks for having me
Jay certainly how can I help I'm calling
because I've just recently started
following your show on YouTube and
getting some that advice as I'm trying
to make my way out of some debt that I
pursued after not working for a bit of
time so I was just served with papers
yesterday's from the sheriff's office
about some debt that I had with American
Express and I've been following your
show and just seeing the advice you've
given other people as far as how to deal
with this a lawsuit with American
Express button I just feel like I have
kind of unique circumstances and that I
am working now again and I'm in a better
place to be able to tackle my debts than
I was when I was first not able to make
my payments I just don't know how to go
about working with them now that I've
been serving papers yeah Charles okay so
how much do you owe that makes some kind
of sense
eleven eleven thousand five hundred
dollars yes and how long has it been
since you paid them anything
I think it's been eight months or so
really that's all maybe maybe 11 I'm
trying to think it must have been last
June that houses the paperwork again
yeah okay so it's probably been a year
or more okay maybe maybe it's been a
year and I know it's unusual for them to
actually sue you even if it's eleven
five after only eight months but a might
you never know with American Express
they're pretty an unwieldy Bunch the
what is your income now oh that's
excellent kind of it good
okay yeah I know which other day I
wasn't able to pay before it's because I
wasn't working I actually moved to
Chicago from
mmm living option savings trying to get
a job I did not get a job for almost a
year which was very unusual and the job
that I took when I which is my kind of
job started off as part-time and tenth
incomes what do you do I was working
what do you do I work once I was on
nonprofit how old are you I just turned
40 how much other debt do you have I
have about 20,000 total 20,000 40,000
40,000 okay and what is the other 30
that's all credit cards okay all right
no student loans no student loans no car
payments I don't own anything in my name
have any money left in savings no
because I try to pay towards everything
that I can when I can so you have
nothing lived you know no just my
day-to-day spending basically my rent
not all my your money in your checking
account but that savings that you've
been living off up for a year is gone
yeah I don't have any more savings
because I have to live off of it when I
was unemployed yeah
okay so you've learned your lesson on
jumping out of the boat or jumping off
the dock before the boat pulls up yeah
yeah you got pretty wet didn't you okay
so here's what you do the attorney that
is on the lawsuit papers is a
manufacturing mill if you can imagine a
factory with widgets going down a
conveyor belt being stamped and robotic
ly screwed on - do you know what I'm
saying you're one of those this is very
personal to you this is not personal to
this attorney or their office they are a
huge operation if they're doing
collections for MX they may actually be
even on staff with MX they may not even
be an independent attorney operation
they may just be a long a staff lawyer
okay but they do tens of thousands
these all the time okay and so it's very
impersonal doesn't matter to them and so
you can't get your little feelings hurt
in this process you're going to be tough
and just don't be surprised that they
don't care about you because I can
promise you American Express doesn't
care about you they never have in this
transaction and they certainly don't now
okay so this is a simple thing call the
attorney and begin to negotiate with
them eh
when did you get served this week
literally just yesterday so let me try
to explain to you okay on a scale of
1,000 when that guy knocked at your door
you were at nine hundred to a thousand
freakout mode yeah on a scale of 1 to
1000 when they sent you this piece of
paper they are a 1 it does not matter to
them a it's not their money B it's just
a job see it's one of 10,000 cases they
have on their desk okay you're kind of
getting the idea yeah you you're one of
the star you're one of the cars in the
factory that's being bolted on and the
people bolting on you have no emotion
about building you you are not a
custom-made car when you're dealing with
M X so all of that to say just play it
cool don't give a rip because they don't
give a rip don't let them abuse you
don't let them yell let you don't let
them say stupid things to you just say
if you're gonna do that I'm gonna teach
you how to talk to a freaking dial tone
your parents or cousins if you think
you're gonna mistreat me so here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna just offer
some money per month and probably two or
three hundred bucks a month we'll get
this going again so I should offer to
pay monthly instead of oh yeah
absolutely because I you don't have a
lump sum darling I do well I know that
you told me you didn't have any savings
no I don't I have an open line of credit
though that I don't want to put
it towards credit but if it would get
them off my back well yeah if they'll
take three thousand bucks and settle it
which they might yeah go hit the line of
credit and settle it all right because
that would be like low interest through
well I'd be like a 70% discount doesn't
matter when you reduce it from eleven
thousand to three thousand and then turn
around pay it off real fast using your
new wonderful income so yeah I'll call
them and make them a lump sum offer and
just negotiate back and forth definitely
don't give them more than at five
thousand dollars if it's a year plus old
old enough that they sued you they will
take 50 cents on the dollar
probably more like twenty five cents on
the dollar I would offer them twenty
five hundred and start their cash and
I'll send it to you today as soon as you
send me in writing that this settles the
account in full now I can promise you
American Express will lie to you they're
scum so if you don't get this in writing
it never happened so whatever your
settlement offer is you get it in
writing from them and then you send them
a check a cashier's check a prepaid
debit card for only that amount do not
let them have electronic access to your
checking account
yeah just settle it but the point is is
that the this is a non emotional event
for them it's a non-event for them